[Music]
how's it going Wolfgang ant-man and the
wasp is now less than a month from
coming out and just the other day there
were brand new posters that were
released for the movie now as you can
see here there are six different posters
that clearly emphasize the main
characters of the movie and it actually
looks like these posters tell us a
little bit more about the movie than we
previously knew you kind of have to put
some pieces together in order to kind of
see it but I'll tell you my thoughts on
it but first be sure to hit that
subscribe button to stay up to date on
ant-man on the wasp Avengers 4 and all
things Marvel so let's start with our
main man Scott Lang slash the ant-man
the biggest thing about this poster is
that ant-man has a new suit it's not too
different than his original suit but it
is different nonetheless it has a lot
more red to it and it certainly looks
more stealthy there are changes in the
chest play and changes in the abdominal
section as well and really what this
tells us is that he's got an upgrade so
it looks like when ant-man was busy
fighting alongside of Captain America in
civil war dr. Pym and hope were busy
themselves making some upgrades to the
gear and we've already seen some of
those upgrades into trailer with the
wasp who is in this poster as well
flying alongside the write of ant-man
perhaps ant-man got some of the upgrades
that the wasp has wings and blasters now
dr. Pym has already stated that when
ant-man was given his first suit he
actually had that technology back then
but maybe it's something that his new
suit will now have obviously not the
wings those are just for the wasp and if
you look right above Evangeline Lilly's
name you can see little ant-man standing
there all proud and in this poster we
have Michael Douglas as dr. Pym dr. Pym
of course is the scientist that
discovered that you can actually access
the quantum room his wife Janet Van Dyne
is the first person to bear the mantle
of the wasp
and she disappeared into the quantum
realm after sacrificing herself to
disable a Soviet nuclear missile since
ant-man went inside the quantum realm
and was
able to return to the real world dr. pam
has a spark of new hope that he can
somehow get his wife back and that is
what the majority of ant-man and the
wasp is gonna be about exploring the
quantum realm and that leads us to this
next poster Janet Van Dyne or the first
wasp now one of the main things here is
that there's a poster just for her in
the first ant-man movie we learned that
she got lost in the quantum realm and
they didn't know if she was alive or she
was dead now clearly she's alive and not
only that it appears that she's going to
be a major character in ant-man on the
wasp so again
ant-man on the wasp is going to really
explore the quantum realm and it seems
like when they go inside the quantum
realm they're going to find her at some
point in time it has been said that
there are dangers inside the quantum
realm and if you take a look at her suit
underneath the trenchcoat type of thing
that she's wearing her at wasp suit
looks pretty banged up and her face
looks very intense it looks kind of like
she's seen some stuff she's the original
wasp so it seems like she's been
fighting inside of the quantum room or
maybe she's used the quantum realm and
discovered how it works and she has gone
into other dimensions and two other time
periods and two other realities who
knows but I do think that she is going
to be a major contributor to whatever
time-travel devices the Avengers will
use in Avengers 4 to go back in time and
try to prevent Thanos to snap so keep an
eye out for her when you watch ant-man
and the wasp the next poster I'd like to
talk about is ghost I've said many
things on ghosts so far and I've even
done a single video just on the origin
story of ghosts and you can check out
that video in the link above now they've
changed the origin story completely
either that or they're just completely
skipping over the origin story and this
is way into the future for ghosts but
originally ghost is a man but obviously
not in the movie you can see Hannah and
John came in as plain ghosts and
originally she is an Iron Man villain
she dismantles huge corporations from
the inside so we've already kind of seen
her role as the villain in the trailers
where Lois says dr. Pym there's crazy
creepy ghosts stole your tech and that's
what ghost does
hacks inside these big corporations and
takes them down from the inside biggest
thing about ghosts is that the suit that
she wears makes her able to walk through
things walls cars people etc and in the
comics the suit can turn invisible not
sure if they're gonna bring that into
the movie but it could probably happen
now having said all this about ghosts
there have been rumors and I personally
believe them and have kind of thought
this before as well that she will not be
the main villain of ant-man and the wasp
I actually think that she is just this
super hacker that was hired to steal
Hank Pym technology by dr. bill foster
or otherwise known as Black Goliath Bill
Foster is originally Hank pimp's
assistant in the comics he then later on
goes on his own and tries to develop his
own Pym particle so I think black
Goliath / dr. bill Foster is the main
villain in ant-man on the loss because I
think he hired ghosts to steal Hank Pym
technology because he was at a
standstill with his own technology and
it's clear from the trailers when Bill
Foster says his record was 21 feet and
then ant-man says mine was 65 so that's
my prediction bill foster / black lieth
is the real villain and ant men on the
wasp and ghost is just a person for hire
and may even turn good by the end of the
movie but what do you guys think are you
excited to see ant-man on the wasp I
know I am because I'm really excited to
see how it connects into Avengers for
I'm curious to see what the post-credits
scene is gonna be like to see what they
really give us as far as information I
also wonder if Captain Marvel will be
mentioned at all scene as they said that
she has a connection to the quantum
realm as well but we have less than a
month to find out let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below
and if you enjoyed this video please hit
that thumbs up button and be sure to
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on ant-man on the Los Avengers for
all things Marvel DC and superhero thank
you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]